their final welcome ceremony was their
most powerful
let's hurry bowing in appreciation to
their Maori hosts the Duke and Duchess
haven't had to fight to get attention
during this tour the images have been
striking a powerful couple who've done
and said all the right things it is an
honour for us to be here in this
magnificent meeting house to meet you
and spend time at the side of the lake
Meghan was given her own Maori cloak a
symbol of protection now she's pregnant
and a sign of respect
she has attracted a very loyal
international following if she wants to
achieve something she's going to achieve
it because it's just her mindset and
it's amazing their first major tour was
always going to be a test with 76
engagements over 16 days they have
braved the rain met politicians followed
in the Queen's footsteps and hung out
with the locals
[Music]
Prince Harry do you want to come and
tell us how you found the tour Prince
Harry
didn't want to talk about it but if
you're measuring crowd reaction and
media coverage it has been a successful
trip in four different countries we've
seen them meeting the crowds and it has
been striking how popular megan has been
Prince Harry of course has been
alongside her shaking hands and giving
hugs but he has seemed much more serious
and statesmen like he is different after
all he is now preparing to be a family
man the parents to be just missed out on
the arrival of this rare Kiwi chick it
is of course their own baby news that
has been the biggest talking point their
final stop in New Zealand was a tranquil
one among the redwood trees of Rotorua
only a year ago they got engaged and
you'd think they'd still be finding
their feet this tour has shown them to
be a confident and impressive royal
partnership who together and now looking
forward to life as a family of three
Rhiannon Mills Sky News in Rotorua